yeah i think most of your audience can
appreciate that if you
as a culture had a monopoly on the
conversation for a century
as the progressives had and you start
losing control of that monopoly
it is going to look like chaos to you
and your
tension and fear is going to be palpable
and that tension and fear is going to be
contagious so some so some very very bad
people are very very worried about
losing their stature and status
in our society and that should make
right thinking people very very happy
it's locals week here on the reuben
report and i'm doing mini interviews
with creators on why they decided to
become less reliant on big tech
and instead own their content and
community
and livelihood with locals.com joining
me today is the willy wonka of politics
himself
michael malus welcome back to the reuben
report thanks dave
i thought you were going to be in one of
your michael malus get ups dressed as
tulsi gabbard or b
arthur or somebody but you're just
giving me regular malice
oh no i'm dressed like a little mermaid
right now
from the bottom down well that's the
mermaid part yeah
that's the mermaid part all right malice
so before we get into why
uh why you're on locals and and you've
had incredible success there actually
um i thought i should probably give you
a little
credit because you've been predicting
the disintegration of everything for
quite some time
and as a matter of fact you relish in it
but also
point to a way that it will not be all
horrible and i think that's what people
are worried about
help me out with this yeah i think most
of your audience can appreciate that if
you as a culture had a monopoly on the
conversation for a century
as the progressives had and you start
losing control of that monopoly
it is going to look like chaos to you
and your
tension and fear is going to be palpable
and that tension and fear is going to be
contagious so some so some very very bad
people are very very worried about
losing their stature and status
in our society and that should make
right thinking people very very happy
uh and this should be something that's
an opportunity for hope you know you
don't
tear down a building and it just it's
not like a snap of fingers and then it's
like a new building's there
there's going to have to be that
transition period which is going to be
ugly so this ugliness is kind of like a
medic you know
if you've ever had coming out both ends
that's basically what we're seeing
uh the body politic is approaching
itself of the poison
yeah what do you think it looks like
like regardless of who wins perhaps you
want to make a prediction but like in a
year from now like when we get to that
other side
the rebuild side what do you what do you
think that looks like well the beauty of
chaos is you have no id way knowing what
it's going to look like i mean
i think we all remember in 2016 after
trump got elected
we were like what does this mean like
none of us had
any clue what a donald trump presidency
would look like on the one hand it could
have been like an arnold schwarzenegger
governorship of california
where he's kind of this like middle of
the road like lefty republican and ends
up destroying the republican party
forever
or he could have gone full kind of
giuliani plus
law and order let's bring out the wood
chippers or the guillotines or whatever
and it's kind of been a mix a lot of
it's much more rhetorical than
otherwise but uh the other concern is
you know we don't know what a biden
presidency would look like
there's two scenarios one is biden's
going to be a moderate
democrat biden has been very anti-crime
in his career
biden is the one who took down bernie
sanders not president trump
or biden is going to be weak and
ineffectual and what
black lives matter is basically going to
be running the country and antifa is
going to be around the country
either snares and and the courts can be
packed and any kind of right-wing gains
at a
legal level will be lost forever so both
of these scenarios are also plausible
there so we have no way of knowing all i
know is that uh
people who are comfortable are going to
be made uncomfortable
and that historically is a good thing
but either way
you want less of these people in our
lives is that fair to say
malice right so when they're running
around like chickens with their heads
cut off
possibly hopefully literally that is
going to be good
because when they're fighting each other
and they can't get their stuff together
that gives them less of an opportunity
to try to inflict their schemes on us
and here's another thing that should be
very very exciting for a lot of people
ron paul and then president trump have
legitimized the anti-war position
within the republican party which had
been the case before
with the rise of neocons and george w
bush especially became
part and parcel republicanism imagine if
joe biden
without some sort of enormous 9 11 event
or even maybe with one god forbid
sat down and or president trump on a
second term said we're all going to war
he would not have the ability to form
that coalition
that historically past presidents have
so to have that chaos
and that lack of ability to form a
consensus is in this case literally
saving hundreds of thousands of lives
well malice it's that sort of insight
that's why i love you that's why i
quote you all the time and you've been
uh
a voice an odd voice of reason somehow
in these crazy times and your book is
right over there
it's right off camera right now anywho
this is a good segue to sort of why
you're on locals because you were the
third person on there
um and i i hand selected you i said this
guy will be perfect
when we were just sort of seeding it
just to who could be the test people
um why did you think that doing
something
off big tech was was going to be good
for you
it was such a no-brainer and i was
looking for an alternative i was on
patreon before
and here are the advantages i had with
locals i do not ever have to worry
that i'm going to make a video or send
out a tweet
and have everything i've created
vanished overnight
i don't have to worry about not having a
recourse first of all i could call you
up or you would call me you'd be like
hey this is inappropriate let's figure
this out number one so no i have a call
in to the guy at the top
but number two is well i for the record
i certainly won't say that to you
it's your site we're we're just giving
you the tools what you do with those
tools is up to you my personal you want
to play with this fighter cause we can
play with this like
no but in all seriousness that was a
huge advantage second
the vibe of locals is this was a place
where me
and people who like what i do and
respect what i do are welcome
as opposed to being regarded as
something to put up with
and an embarrassment and something to
apologize about i don't think people
appreciate
to what extent the employees at let's
suppose spotify
are driven crazy that their platform is
being used
to further the views of people that they
regard as literal nazis or twitter
or facebook so when you have that kind
of
disconnect between the people running
the site and the creators who are
in the jewish um it it's very reassuring
to know
you're not going to have to sit down
with someone and explain no
i would have been against the holocaust
and would have been a victim
yeah so part of this of course is that
there's a paywall
so i think you let you let you have a
minimum right but you let people come on
for whatever whatever they want to pay
and i know some people must be saying
but wait a minute michael malus wrote a
book called the new right he's an expert
at what the trolls are up to why would
he want to be in a place where there are
no trolls because trolls won't pay you
no they all my followers are trolls well
i'm a professional troll
i i trolled kamala harris very
successfully i troll
people all the time on twitter uh
trolling at its best is the art of
exploiting someone's weaknesses and
turning them to former
uh for the sake of the broader audience
so it is impish it is mischievous it is
fun
it is very much willy wonka but it's not
about being hate
hateful me just telling you hey dave
you're sob or that that's not trolling
that's just being a jerk
so i think people enjoy uh my followers
certainly the people who support me
enjoy how effective puncturing these
balloons are
of these pompous people who have
presumed to put themselves in position
of authority
despite being such mediocre people
here's a but one great example i
frequently use
i'll just ask them have you ever
considered the possibility that you're
the bad guys
and just that one simple question to the
likes of these you know
operatives really gets people excited
and gets them
some of them uh to wonder you know what
maybe i don't have it as much figured
out as i'd like to think i do
yeah do you think the ship has totally
sailed with big tech that we're
basically just
at the end of it now like you know we
all are on borrowed time there basically
no uh but i think that you know at any
time you have any industry
it's going to at first ossify into like
four to ten
you know major establishments it was the
case in publishing you know he had six
companies is the case in music you know
he had a certain number of labels
but after a certain time like in music
like in self publishing and in
the internet uh they might have a
disproportionate amount of impact on the
market but they're not going to have
that monopoly control
uh that we're seeing to some extent now
the only people there's a very few
people who are like completely
you know driven off the internet uh the
rest they're having issues with it and
the fact that you are creating a
competitive advantage
alternative to them really is an issue
because
just if i'm not political why would i if
i have to choose between patreon and
locals right and they're both
comparable in their advantages but this
has the disadvantage of i might lose my
account overnight
for some political reason whereas here
that's not going to be a concern
and i'm going to have a similar ability
to attract audiences why wouldn't i go
to this other one
have you booted anyone out of your
locals community yet i have not ever had
to
i've never had to warn anyone i mean
having that velvet rope
so how i have it set up is it's free if
you want to watch read everything i have
exclusive content
it's five bucks a month if you want to
support me and then you could
participate
and whatever i we had not even any
arguments so
the fact that i'm so big on people
establishing their own boundaries
and being pro-joy and not being so
sneering
uh i think self-selects for a certain
quality type of person
yeah do you find it changes your mood on
a day-to-day basis like i open twitter
and then it's like a half hour later and
i'm like
oh what did i just see it's like it's
like bathing in vomit
and then i open up my locals and i'm
like oh these are all good
interesting people sharing things about
themselves how pleasant
when i go on tw that is for many for my
community the locals is being used as an
alternative facebook
because when people are posting things
about their personal lives or someone at
work they don't have to worry about that
from high school casting aspersions on
them or screen capping them right
for me twitter and you and i have
different twitter experiences because
i'm much more of a brawler on twitter
and i you know monetize the haters you
know uh you know if someone comes at me
i say would be a shame if people bought
me this book i don't really want just
despite you
and yesterday i just made 100 bucks you
know to buy you know this
antique book so i think you and i have
very different experiences on twitter
and you get a lot
surprisingly you get disproportionately
more hate than i do and i can't figure
out why that is i'm not being sarcastic
i walked malice you know why come on
they can't let somebody walk
yeah yeah yeah right yeah that's true
you know
yeah you're apostate you're an apostate
yeah yeah
it's religion you know you can't let the
non-believers walk away what's next for
michael malus
in this situation my next book is called
the white pill
um and i'm working on it now and this is
really going to be a manifesto that's
going to make people very excited
and very hopeful about the future of
this country because we've beaten some
very bad people before people don't
realize how bad it used to be
are you surprised that people don't
realize that we will get through to this
i mean this is sort of where we started
a few minutes ago but like
that people feel like a certain amount
of people just feel like oh
we've crossed some rubicon and now it's
just endless chaos forever like they
sort of don't understand that these
things
are cyclical and that it will it will
get better
i think it's a very useful technique to
tell
your opponents preemptively that you
can't win and no hope is lost
because then you have to get a scratch
in the battle so this has very much been
a message coming out
from corporate media that it's over give
it up you guys can't win
and uh you know we're raised to trust
these people raise to believe them
and some of us will trust them and
believe them and then it's like oh wait
no
they've been lying to me about
everything since i was a kid they're
lying about this
they want me to give up and here's the
thing even if you lose
at least you could lose your head held
high and to
give up for the sake of these people and
say you can't beat these college
professor types that you see
these little clips them all the time to
me is an absurdity
everyone knows what the red pill is
malice what's the white pill
the white pill is the possibility of
hope that the good guys will win
that's it that's it all right pimp
yourself out
pimp out your locals it's a
malice.locals.com
and i i'm glad to see you all there
you're a simple man michael malus
i look forward to seeing you next time
in full uh mermaid outfit
and keep up the good work my friend
it'll be a big splash
take care dave if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell